so how did you guys like end up linking
up was it
similar to the tv show because the tv
show was [ __ ] awesome
it was definitely similar you know like
i said i had a um
time in a music career right working on
stuff with tiger and everything and he
had a manager that was managing him
so he reached out to me one day when i
was doing bad you know i'm saying i'm
down bad on the block i remember like it
was yesterday
i got a text message from aunt he like
yo
i got this new artist i'm working with
i'm managing him he's like i want you to
work with him you know i'm saying he did
no concerts yet right and i want you to
bring that swag out of him you know
saying that and then i just linked up
with him
at a studio in santa monica it's crazy
because i was gandering out the gate
you know i come from the rap world so
i'm like building my image and my brand
even though i had nothing i still had
the the the dream and the vision
of course i pull up with a fake
cameraman fake personal assistant you
know i'm walking in the building feeling
good you know what i'm saying
and he didn't like me at first he
thought like oh man this dude it's too
much
but i love this music out the gate i
always thought he was talented and knew
he was a genius instantly you know i'm
saying knew he had bars
because luka you know been around yeah i
was able to see the talent in him
fast and then after the meeting
we became cool but he told me straight
up like man at first it was a little bit
too much but he understood
that like yo that's what you need in a
rap game
you got to put on it's a show you feel
me so
it all worked out man and now we don't
season two dave it's crazy
yeah no it's crazy because like i think
it also like you were there like
because i think there was like a weird
period of dickies career where like
people weren't really taking them
serious as a rapper oh yeah sure and
then he had a couple of those freestyles
that were [ __ ] insane but then like
he started to make like real records you
know because i always like when i would
tell people about a little dicky i would
be like yo
you got to watch the video to get it
like or the early stuff
you know like you're like yo you got to
see the video like
if you just listen to the song you might
be like what the [ __ ] is this
but if you see the video it brings it's
a whole different [ __ ]
thing it's you got to see the visual um
but i think that like save that money
was like such a
well well executed idea and at the
timing of like
having rich homie quan at the time and
oh yeah yeah it was like it was just
like a perfect storm like yeah
this is a real [ __ ] record like this
guy can make real records but like
um like you've been around dickie from
the jump like
what was the for you like when did you
realize like oh [ __ ]
there's like uh this guy can like be
here forever type [ __ ] was it right away
or was there like a moment that happened
like
uh after the team westward freestyle
yeah that [ __ ] was crazy after the 10
westward freestyle
like just to be in the building just to
see it because like we in the rap game
so this is
worse so this is hip-hop like all the
like when people make songs for the
radio and you know like okay when they
specifically say oh this is gonna be the
hit
i love all that too but i love the like
the raw moments you know what i'm saying
so when i seen him do that at tim
westwood and how he killed it i'm like
man
this is what the game needs you know
what i'm saying people like to laugh and
you know do the videos and stuff but i
like the fact that he actually has
bars like i could say yo ld can spit
with the best of them
right i feel comfortable about it you
know what i mean because i'm old school
you know like
so it mean a lot to me just to see him
be able to shred the mic like that